[Music]
I'm about to get stabbed all right so
we're here at the what is this place
called
Beverly Hills fencers Club and as you
can see there aren't any other fencers
in here I didn't know I needed to bring
my own
I'm gonna call Ethan and I'm gonna see
if he's free he is on the other side of
town so I have no idea Tyler's out of
town ride I'd ask him
it's 953 I bet he's not awake didn't
even answer
god damn it okay so I don't have any
other friends
okay um so Carla I don't have anyone at
the moment like you wouldn't stab me
yeah you would you mind being the person
that stabs me oh no not at all honestly
no one wants me to play with them you
know you're the one that's gonna be
teaching me so I assume you know I do so
I'm gonna be teaching you the sport of
the epic fencing okay and FA is the
modern-day rapier and it's a three-sided
blade made out of steel and it has a
button on the very end of it the
depresses sending electrical current
through here into here you have a wire
you're attached to a fencing strip and
when the button depresses on the soccer
meaty parts of you a light will go off
don't want to point the weapon at
somebody who is not wearing a face
protection mask like you just did yes
so I'm gonna do is give you a basic
lesson in fencing so we'll start with
the footwork and the positioning what
you might want to stretch out a little
bit have you done I'm so limber you are
Solan yeah I did silk dancing last week
so I'm pretty good
a little bit of stretching out maybe and
this one's a bit one where you cross
your one foot over the other and just
reach down and touch okay yeah well I
have a have a natural like a I've got a
mental block of putting both hands down
okay it's not a physical inability it's
just like hey I don't want to like I'm
afraid of these pants are very fragile
that's a good thing to relieve stress as
you're stabbing somebody with the sword
it's very relaxed I don't imagine I'm
gonna be actually stabbing anybody today
I imagine I'm getting stabbed no no no
I'll give you a nice little lesson and
you'll get to stab me oh okay so that'll
be five back combing over there oh yeah
much fun to stab as me because I can
fight back so that should be more fun
for you doesn't sound fun oh yeah
that'll be fun you know I like beating
up on defenseless people okay let me
show you the first basic positions and
that's and you're right-handed right so
you take your right foot and you place
it one way like this and then you bring
your back foot up this is called the
ready position your hands are down and
you're preparing to salute to your
opponent how you salute is you extend
your sword arm to your opponent mm-hmm
you raise it up to the sky and then
sweep down position was pretty easy all
you do is take a step forward with just
your front foot and place it down and
now bend both knees and Center your
weight hey relax fencing is really a
loose limber sport and then
it relaxed not that much there you go
so basically you're on the on guard
position like this I really have my
wrist just well the reason is you don't
want it in front of your body you want
to keep it back behind your shoulders
slightly but not too much so it's
uncomfortable and so this way when you
extend your arm you'll be able to it's a
combat sport and if a is first blood so
you're not actually going to believe but
it used to be first blood so from the
top of your head to the soles of your
feet is a valid target Oh
so whoever hits first wins so you
wouldn't want to put your full chest
forward like this because you're a
bigger target so you're trying to keep
your target areas small so that when you
reach and extend your opponent doesn't
have a larger target right maximize make
sense
I'll give you okay good so your front
toe is always facing straight and
forward and when you want to take a step
forward you just walk forward like this
one to just watch boy that's a lunge
actually recover up oh yeah so you know
how I saw you walking you just
I dunno how to walk okay so your feet
need to be separated about 12 inches
apart your heels are going underneath
your shoulders now just take a step like
this one - that's it yeah that's called
an advance when you're moving you want
to try to move really smoothly so you
sit down on your legs bend your knees
okay don't stick out your butt there you
go
they're somewhere in between them okay I
don't know what to do so now when I take
a step forward you take a step back now
you step back and I took a step back and
you take a step forward there you go
you're advancing I'm retreating and now
I take a step board and you retreat in
all events what we try to do is hit each
other from these stances so I'll come
forward and try to stab you and as you
extend your arm you can try to stab me
so we're moving back and forth that's
right and that's it yeah it's it's kind
of it you see these panels here and they
have long port each of these ports are a
port for two people backwards and when I
take a step backwards to take a step
forward okay yes already scared yes no
it's mine
I don't think I was nervous going into
this because I'm like pensive just seems
like one of those supports where like
everything thrives on such a small
margin of error that I'm just like in a
panic the entire time um yeah that
happens with people sometimes when they
first go but you won't have to worry
about that why I'm not going to be scary
you're scary right now sometimes you
can't hit somebody by just moving back
and forth of course because they'll just
step away from your plate so you do
something called the lunge so that means
you extend your sword arm first like
this lift up your front toes slightly
and take a big step forward like that
now we're comedy guy okay so it goes
like this relax all you have to do is
extend your arm straight the dip your
front toe and take a big step your back
hand goes down like this that's it yeah
there's one thing that I've noticed on
all these skills that have done force
back riding silks spinning and now
fencing they use the interior leg
muscles
lunging back like this is just all inner
thigh muscle yeah also if you notice me
frowning this whole time it's just
because I had my wisdom teeth taken out
like last week and my cheeks are still
puffy and I can't really move my job
okay good it's not that I'm just like yo
this whole time it's it's just because
that's it this is my smile thank you
recover head stays up it's not advanced
fine if you lift up your head like this
the blade could go and hit you in the
throat so you want to make sure that
your chin is level not down then you're
recovered and then when you extend drop
your back hand down like this there you
go perfect why the backhand like a swim
like pushing through there that's it
yeah just sort of like that backwards
see you say scary things like that it's
just teasing hey it's gonna be fine
you'll see them next week okay this is
called an underarm protector or a
plaster on and this helps to protect the
sword arm put this over your head like
this oh not like that sorry over your
head and then stick your arm in there
it's like a bib kind of like your jack
shirt on it's just a nice flannel I know
you're gonna be very warm I'm fine I'm a
naturally sweaty man you tell me to
relax I literally don't you look a
little stressed I'm a little bit yeah
but don't worry it's super fun fencing
is really fun that's what you keep
saying
perfect do I look good handsome handsome
the medium pretty much across the board
except for my head my head is had
gigantic it is I got like a triple XL
head whoa
do you not have a triple XL mask okay so
the fencing mask is covering your ears
and your face and your throat right but
it's not covering it all the back of
your head what's illegal in fencing is
turning around and running are you sure
about that
I'm totally possible why is it illegal
because it's dangerous we don't want to
get hit in the back of the head with a
sword right I mean my back in my head is
my strongest part so I'm pretty sure
they're capable of withstanding the most
punishment what we're gonna do is we're
gonna put this over the back of your
head like this pull it down either flip
I told you okay I'm gonna have to adjust
it all your face out it's fine I keep
saying it's fine you're like me whenever
something goes horribly wrong bleeding
yet I mean at all ever there we go okay
nice big head thank you how's that it's
is it's not comfortable I'll tell you
that no no I my extra special extra
special oh boy oh that is much better
don't mean to torture you Rania you know
you say that but the tone of your voice
suggests that you you are meaning to
torture I can't scratch my nose why does
it seem like you're getting a lot more
armor than I am although I do like to
tell you that but I'm not going
- so much I'm going to let you hit me
and then something wrong what I'm gonna
do a lot wrong because I've never done
it before that's too bad
so you have a way with words that mix
everything you say we just not pressed
it so let me give you your sword
this should fit your hand they come in
different sizes so if it doesn't feel
comfortable that's fine I'm not too
particular at this point yes but we
might not be able to fit what's wrong
with my hand
they ain't gonna die I'm pretty sure
she's brought me or to kill me and the
rain is gonna wash away my blood there
are holes in the floor for blood to leak
through I'm gonna die try this your hand
goes here all your fingers so want two
fingers one here one there and one here
and you have a light and the thumb wraps
around like that so you're holding it
like this like a gun yes exactly
actually good die it's called a pistol
grip so I had to tell you it's not
swashbuckling you know wah wah it's
small quick precise actions with the
point of the blade moving forward
because I took off my glasses so no no
it's fine I'll just be in a disadvantage
that you are and not necessarily like a
fencing mask I'm good without it no I'm
fine
that are worrisome well you said this is
like martial arts so it's like you got
it you got a school y'all louder you are
the faster you go okay those are
touching then straight through the sky
all you don't lean into it or anything
like that just reach out and hit me push
and when you push your hand goes up
slightly keep your knees ready
I come not really a good judge of
distance right now wait look it's Dennis
here and then wait for music a few tips
for you to go back on larger extend your
armpit there perfect
very good now you're gonna try it with a
lunch so I'm gonna step back a little
further extend your arm now aim up here
so it's a blobby area and your knees
lift up your front toe take a big step
forward and hit me boom and put your
back hand down now look in the mirror
how beautiful you look beautiful now I
step
okay step back step back
now I open up my sword like this
foolishly and step forward just extend
your arm
do I not step forward what I'm doing um
no if I step forward just extend your
arm so now I try to block you because
you've stabbed me many times so as you
extend your arm I try to block you see
uh-huh instead of pushing back you just
go underneath and stab me just to get
like a gauge of progress so then I have
something internalized so people at home
can get a skill-based I'm gonna do this
like on the age of the person that I
could beat at this point I feel like I
could beat a one-year-old at this point
because they put in the worldís or
exactly so we're gonna go one year old
two year old you get up to ten yeah and
then if I could beat I I bet there's
some pretty skilled ten year olds at
fencing
there are yeah around me but I want to
get through those childhood years
because I feel like there's some babies
that could really beat down okay all
right that sounds good in a creepy way
probably disengage extend your arm oh
you have to use your fingers to twirl
the blade underneath so it's like just a
wrist movement I know it's a finger
movement actually so your wrist doesn't
actually move it's the fingers rolling
the point of the blade
that's on wiggling my fingers yeah so if
I press this way you just see how fast
that is well if I press that way what if
you lose your grip on it I'll stab you
three three
you have to go around it before you step
Rodi right don't you stay but to die
extend good lunch
good back fingers hurt my shoulders a5
my fingers just trying to squeeze this
thing it's it's actually my fencing
master that taught me how to fence he
said it's like holding a bird in your
hand you don't want to crush the bird
but you don't want to let it fly either
in between there so it's not a really
it's not a death grip because your
fingers need to move faster beat attack
okay so the blade away from me
so I snap it and I extended hit oh you
said Alba for Irish no the wrists ready
I was holding my bird my burden dad so
it's a little snap and then an extension
see we'll make a little X here see and
then you're gonna and it's
and hit me okay ready very good now
we're gonna try what we call a
counter-attack mm-hmm so now I'm
attacking you and I foolishly drop my
point and you just extend so because the
arm is out forward yes because I drop
you can extend and hit me before I reach
you see so is every mistake foolish yes
okay you have to be very patient is a
slower than weapons because there are no
rules there is no judge saying oh you
made this like this hit whoever hits
first wins right throw it
no you can't throw your sword because
then yes but if you throw it what will
you protect yourself with when you miss
me well what if I don't miss you're
going down
beat attack lunch lunch recover
disengage tip retreat I do to you extend
retreat I always got to be mindful of
the distance yes killer so do you want
to try a little fancy I mean I'm gonna
lose but yeah your this is your starting
line right here and you want to stand in
the middle of the fencing strip so you
want to come forward
[Music]
between these two was that your
[Applause]
yeah let's do one more for just fun
[Music]
let me say good about good bout you're
barely sweaty oh okay I don't believe in
water okay only beer now I can't drink
beer either well there you have it yeah
I just I want you to go as if you were
in a real battle
I just want to experiment a fire saying
that but I don't I want people to know
what it's really like no matter what you
do even try it's gonna destroy me so
oh I can see now I've got the advantage
[Music]
it's really terrifying change no no do
all the fancy stuff I know you don't
want to but
[Music]
I feel I should have done a lot of
things yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
No
[Music]
you know maybe for your sake are you
you're okay
yeah why what do you see you know I have
no deep breathing exercises really
that's good for practice we practice
like this for about two hours of bowden
with a normal group how long we've been
going like three and a half four hours
probably picked that up
well you can always come back tonight
and sense with the guys
oh yeah well the 10 year old ok so just
give me another 30 minutes I'll be up to
there a long time
I'm more sweaty than I was when I did
the silk spinning I tell you that oh
yeah yeah all right well thank you so
much how I will use these skills to
protect myself on the streets
I mean what's faster calling 9-1-1 er
yeah yeah as long as I don't tell them
I'm about to do it oh yeah that's true
you don't say here I come why did I
literally say here I come no I think
going from a long distance is never a
good I was an aim of the school here I'm
Beverly Hills fencers Club guys if you
want to learn fencing go to Beverly
Hills fencers Club Website will be in
the description go check it out Carla
cause I was gonna say Carla your
favorite and starker Marla will show you
the business and if you're lucky you can
wear my jacket if you want my residual
sweat
I think we'll be washing it this is
where the prodigy started the 29 year
old prodigy we started fencing late I'm
really gonna dominate the geriatrics
bracket well you all have to wait until
you're 44 that got a lot of time to
practice yeah a lot of time to practice
pretty well today actually I think you
should take it out really yeah you did
pretty well you sure I'm except for
those minors stabbing things where you
threw your body on my blade but beyond
that I have this martyr complex I just
can't help it yeah that's really good
but I think you didn't work well I think
you you know you're coordinated and you
can move easily and you didn't look that
careful yeah yeah thank you
well the mask was really blocking a lot
and it not being able to see me without
your glasses I suppose oh yeah yeah just
imagine there was like a monster in
front of me if you want to see more
stuff that I try in the future let me
know down the comments again all the
link is in the description below to
check it out if you want to try fencing
for yourself thank you so much and as
always I'll see you in the next one
thank you bye bye